So I've been thinking a lot
about this idea of biology
as something with almost
a kind of agency, right?
A kind of directionality.
Not to get metaphysical
here, but you could actually
think of the 10 trillion
cells that self organize
and collaborate to become
the meta organism that
is a human being means
that biology seems
to exhibit a kind of
protoplasmic yearning, a desire
to self organize.
There seems to be
conditions in this universe
that engender novelty,
complexity sprouts, mind
emerges from matter and then
starts to manipulate matter
at the level of the atom
with nanotechnology.
It's like human beings
seem to be the cutting
edge, the evolutionary
pinnacle of self awareness
becoming aware of
its becoming, right?
It's almost like the birth of
mind folds the attention back
and looks at its own
heritage and starts
to put itself into context.
The universe comes to know
itself through human beings.
We've decommissioned
natural selection,
Edward O. Wilson
says, and now we
must look deep within
ourselves and decide
what we wish to become.